[Applause]
oh my god it really is Christmas Merry
[Applause]
Christmas season I don't know whether
you guys ever saw when David Bowie
dropped in on big crowds be that yeah
yeah oh yeah I did see that I think
maybe we could all do a song together
sure you know we can't well by the way
there's a mic problem yeah oh there is
we know they're better now I think this
mic works but the audience is not
hearing it as well as we'd like them to
this room isn't doesn't have any
monitors yes I tried to alleviate the
situation before this started yeah they
said they can't do that Chitwood
feedback we had about four weeks every
meeting the club or a special has been
shot wait what let me just see if I
can't make a Christmas miracle and just
turn a couple things but also I want to
say congratulations you guys you guys
got Colin to show up yeah it's really
really difficult for me at Thanksgiving
every year does Colin not do the
Bennington family Thanksgiving call
little-ass well no you're a big star and
god bless you for it you deserve
everything that's happened no I'm back
[Laughter]
because I heard you have to show and
then wait in line to do a one joke one
line and then leave I don't want to work
on a goddamn ma you know why wouldn't
you just say that from the beginning
other than you know like maybe I'll be
there but no I do think about going
there but then I'm like I got my [ __ ]
man I'm like this show we had chip-chip
ursin stop by and the place went mad for
him yes they mad for him and he ended up
with a date with stalker patty yes he
did and oh yeah that could have been you
Colin yeah you could have been with
stalker patty what whose seat am I
sitting in by the way they said somebody
then show no one was it Jesus
by plows how many Christians you boss
Christian I'll help my career yeah yeah
it's a big help in show biz all the
executives Christians so Rob Bennington
you have had quite the year for yourself
well the Bennington show here on faction
talk this is going but is a new your
show yesterday you yummy what was I
doing something about wrestling why what
did I bring up like Larry's abisco the
living legend
yeah I'm a Don Muraco guy oh god I hope
one day he gets a shot at the title
[Laughter]
unbelievable he had on one show you had
Andrew Dice Clay and Quentin Tarantino
yes I mean that's got to be an alternate
for you also Andrew said this he said
one of the big prides of his entire
career this how Jem Norton is doing now
he really - he goes I come back he goes
yeah he was a kid you know what I mean
and I go it's a-you know that's true
thank you I wish I was one of
Tarantino's one more Jim and Sam catch
up with full episodes and interviews
from celebrity guests anytime on demand
using the Sirius XM average